hey this is preshtal Walker
we have Circle o and we have three
points p q and r on its circumference
Circle o has a radius equal to six
the challenge is now to calculate the
area of this shape which looks like a
flower with three petals
so p q and R are centers of arcs that
pass through o the center of the circle
if arcs p q q r and RP are equal
what is the area of the Shaded region
each petal is defined as the
intersection of two circles so the top
petal will be the intersection of the
circles at p and Q and the same thing
goes for Q and R and for R and P
I think Ahmad from Jordan and atish from
India
pause the video if you'd like to give
this problem a try
and when you're ready keep watching to
learn how to solve this problem
to work it out we will focus on
calculating one of the areas of one
petal so consider just this top petal
which is the intersection of the circles
centered at p and Q
Now The Circle at P has radius equal to
six so label this top Point as s so PS
will be equal to 6. Now The Circle at Q
passes through o so we know that it has
the same radius as the circles at o and
P so its radius is equal to six
so qo is equal to 6 and Qs is also equal
to 6. since Circle o has a radius equal
to six OS is also equal to 6.
so now triangle PSO has all three sides
equal to six so it's an equilateral
triangle
so now let's calculate the area of half
of this petal
so the area of half of this petal this
shape is known as a circular segment
this is equal to the area of the
circular sector minus the area of the
equilateral triangle
so if the circle has radius equal to R
this circular sector would have an area
equal to pi r squared times Theta
degrees over 360 degrees
now since the circle would have radius
equal to r that would be the same side
length of the equilateral triangle so
the area of the equilateral triangle
would be r squared times root 3 over 4.
so in this case we know that R is equal
to 6 and this central angle is the same
angle as one of the equilateral triangle
angles so it's equal to 60 degrees
so we could substitute R is equal to six
and Theta is equal to 60 degrees
once we do that we can simplify this
equation
so we have 6 squared pi multiplied by 60
over 360 minus six square root 3 over 4.
this works out to be 6 Pi minus 9 root
3. now we need to calculate the area of
three petals so it takes two of these to
make one petal and then we have three
petals so we need to multiply this area
by 6 to get the entire area and this
works out to be 36 Pi minus 54 root 3
which is approximately equal to 19.57
and that's the answer
thanks for making us one of the best
communities on YouTube see you next
episode of mind your decisions where we
solve The World's problems one video at
a time
foreign